an anti-abortion
anti-lgbt Christian group pulled the
stunt to get themselves refused service
at a restaurant and now you've got a lot
of right-wingers saying they were denied
service for their religion is that
actually what happened I want to start
with this today because it is so
important to understand when we talk
about non-discrimination
differences between beliefs and identity
and this is the perfect example to talk
about that so let's start with an
article that tells us what happened it's
a CV CBS News article restaurant denies
Christian group service over its
anti-abortion and lgbtq stanzas here's
what happened
a restaurant in Richmond Virginia
refused to host a private event for a
Conservative Christian organization over
the group's position on same-sex
marriage and abortion rights the
restaurant is called Metzger bar and
Butchery and it is known as an inclusive
establishment that has rarely refused
service to willing patrons but said it
denied service to the group in an effort
to protect its staff many of whom are
members remember women or members of the
lgbtq community quote we recent recently
we refused service to a group that had
booked an event with us after the owners
of Metzger found out it was a group of
donors to a political organization that
seeks to deprive women in lgbtq persons
of their basic human rights in Virginia
the move was consistent with Metzger's
past practices was made out of respect
for its staff quote we have always
refused service to anyone for making our
staff uncomfortable or unsafe and this
was the driving force behind our
decision all of our staff are people
with rights who deserve dignity and a
safe work environment this is a super
interesting legal story because
discrimination along religious lines
meaning we don't serve Christians would
be against the law but political beliefs
are not protected outside of Washington
D.C and that is what is at the Crux of
this now I'm biased my view here is that
nowhere is there any evidence that these
folks were denied service for being
Christian
they were denied service for their views
on particular issues their view on
abortion their view on LGBT rights now
where it starts to get dicey is that as
we have seen the religious right uh uh
start to behave over the last few years
is to argue well those views are
informed by our religion and by telling
us that those views are what is getting
us banned or refused service you were
effectively discriminating against our
religion because there is no daylight
between our view on abortion and LGBT
rights and our Christian faith
now the other part that's important to
consider is that this was a stunt the
Family Foundation is the name of the
group that did this they obviously knew
about Metzger's history of supporting
inclusivity including LGBT inclusivity
they knew that they tried to book an
event there and after they said no they
started soliciting donations because oh
we've been canceled they've canceled us
where this was a very clear and known
stunt and this was the outcome so
there's a couple different things that I
think are important to talk about uh
from a legal standpoint I can't
adjudicate here whether based on all of
the facts a court would find saying no
was because of Christianity or saying no
was because of political views that are
not protected by non-discrimination law
the truth is we all know there are
progressive Christian groups Progressive
Catholic groups Etc
endless uh uh Jewish groups that have
very different views about abortion
there's no rule that says if you are
quote Christian
you have to have this particular view
about abortion or about LGBT people so
we know that you have other perspectives
there and so
it's obvious that If This Were a
progressive Christian group or a
Christian group that had a let others
decide view we don't like it but let
others decide about abortion or whatever
the case may be they would not have been
refused service and so by definition
that is not religiously based
discrimination the problem is that
thanks to what happened to the Judiciary
in the United States under Donald Trump
one of the biggest victories that
genuinely took place during the Trump
Administration was
the ability of Donald Trump and the
success for Donald Trump of moving the
Judiciary dramatically to the right in
the United States now most prominently
we think about the Supreme Court and of
course that is prominent that's what
most of us know about long public
confirmation hearings we know the names
of these folks Etc
but at many other levels the appointment
of right-wing judges by Donald Trump has
led to a Judiciary that is much more
likely to find
even though really they say it's the
views not the religion you can't
separate those religious views and this
is effectively religiously based
discrimination you must host the Family
Foundation there are judges in the
United States that would find that and
that's very very scary now at the back
or the bottom or the top of this however
you want to describe it
there's always the hypocrisy with these
people they want to have it both ways on
the one hand they want to be able to
discriminate against the LGBT people
whether it's the anti-gay Baker or
whatever story you want to look at they
want that freedom
but they also want everyone else to have
to accept and suck up and allow their
bigotry and their discrimination and
their whatever it may be in the
particular circumstance xenophobia or
homophobia or whatever the case may be
and then they frame it as religious when
they want to do the Discrimination it's
their right because of their religion
and then when they want to demand that
they be serviced they say it's
discrimination not to serve us they want
it both ways there is not
a lot of exciting stuff happening in
Hospitality from the from the pers from
this particular perspective right now
but the right to refuse service is a
real thing and as long as you're not
violating non-discrimination law which
includes religion
Etc uh then you should be allowed to do
it I believe that the restaurant was
well within its rights to say because of
your views they didn't even mention
their religion because if your views we
are not going to offer you service we
will see what it leads to in terms of
lawsuits and if there is an outcome then
we will get to that before you go if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
please make sure to subscribe to my
YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just so search for the David packman
show and all the links are also Down
Below in the video description